you are working with the Russo Brothers  now big fan of those guys really excited  about electric State uh what was it  about that material that said I need to  do this  the fact that  they were so dead set on me playing huh  just  the fact that trust in a director with  an actor it's really unheard of and I  don't really get to experience that very  often so the fact that they wanted me  um only made me want them even more and  to be able to have that opportunity to  make this movie with them has been such  an amazing experience  um and it's just been like a really good  collaborative effort you know it felt  feels like I'm actually working with I  mean real real experienced experienced  team  um their team is incredible the  directors are amazing obviously and I've  got an amazing uh cast to be alongside